very few girls ever cooked for me and
for sure whenever they did I felt like
it was usually a pretty genuine sign of
them like wanting to be with me and that
definitely like with my girl the first
time she could for me was around the
same time that I sort of started to like
realize like oh she loves you like she
really like wants the best for you and
she'll do anything for you and for sure
like I mean on the most basic biological
level I feel like cooking for somebody
is just kind of like providing for them
like and especially if it's decent you
know yeah for me I can't cook I'm
ordering Postmates I'll make you eggs in
the morning if you want that's about all
I got going for me yeah yeah but that's
the whole point of life school and like
um she's also going to talk about just
like the mentality that you should have
as a wife so like like why are you guys
looking for problems like he might be
cheating he might not but like why are
you guys like like literally looking for
pro and just like stuff like that when
it talks more about I'm like kind of
butchering it but she was just telling
me about it but she like literally
trains like women to be wives